[Applause]
[Music] I
love birds. We have something that affects us. Praise be to God,
Lord of the worlds, and we are among the little ones with us. [Music] The
right of our children is the right of our children and our children, and we teach them
about it, and
praise be to God. I mean, they are passionate about it, and we are this
passion that we cannot do without.
[Music]
This has now turned from  Firstly, it was a source of rice, and
this bird is considered to eat it, for example, in four or five
houses, and it will be a source of food for them. [
Music] So the halls are a hobby, a hobby.
It means
breaking the one-day routine. He comes out of his day
and needs something to distract himself from [
Music]
[Applause] [
Music] The
relationship between us and...  The relationship bird
has become like our children. They live
like our children. I mean, a boy. If you were a
little tired, you are the only one who does not get sleep at
night. The same thing flies. The bird gets tired and nothing.
You are the one who is worried and thinks about you.
[Music] [
Applause] [
Music] [
Applause]